yeah we've seen a report that this
government is quite well known to police
in fact is quite well known to the media
here in Sydney but as you say they've
asked us to keep a lid on that at the
moment as they continue on with these
negotiations so reading between the
lines what is that saying to me as the
as the is threat diminished or not I
don't think it has it all we receive two
phone calls this afternoon from the
hostages they called in to our newsroom
directly and I spoke to two women who
were being held hostage what they were
doing they were relaying the gunman's
demands so I could hear him talking and
then the ladies were then relaying those
demands to me we made a decision here
not to to to replay these demands
because police at the time were dealing
directly and that was the advice from
police the demands are all over social
media I can say one of them was that the
government does want to speak to someone
high in authority namely the the Prime
Minister there were a number of other
demands one woman was remarkably calm
and cool
she said she'd had food and water and
she was relatively okay she asked me to
pass on a message to her husband and I
called him I said I can't believe your
partner is so relaxed and common on this
and he said well she's like that she's
cool in a crisis the other lady that
called a bit later was far more agitated
she was agitated because you didn't
think it was happening in fact a lot has
been happening and police are dealing
with this the way they do the New South
Wales Police it's it's one of their
trademarks they allow these negotiations
to go on and on and on they are not
worried about speeding things up they're
not worried about going in and ramming
the place conducting some kind of raid
and as their Deputy Commissioner did say
they will take as long as as long as
they need to so this could stretch into
easily into tomorrow